for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university and the
production of more videos check out move
University calm thank you and enjoy so
next up we've got covalent compounds now
covalent compounds form when atoms of
different elements share electrons okay
and these electrons are specifically
shared between nonmetals ok so in a
covalent compound will have a nonmetal
bound to another nonmetal ok so let's
start with an example in fact let's
start with the simplest example of a
covalent compound and that will be
diatomic hydrogen h2 ok so two hydrogen
atoms coming together and forming a
covalent bond what exactly is happening
how does that how does that situation
occur how do these two separate atoms
end up sharing electrons ok well let's
imagine here we've got a hydrogen atom
over here hydrogen atom over here with
their electron configurations being 1 s1
mean they have one electron they also
have just one proton they have no
neutrons that is the proton and an
electron will call this one on the left
h a the one on the right HB ok so let's
reveal their electrons because I haven't
drawn them in there there they are ok so
what's going to happen is that they're
going to move closer together ok they're
floating a space initially they're gonna
move closer together why are they going
to move closer together well because
we've got a positive charge here in this
proton and AJ and a negative charge here
in this electron NH HB and they're going
to attract each other ok likewise the
same situation will happen between HBS
proton and a chaise electron opposite
charges will attract so that's going to
draw these two atoms closer together ok
so a chaise proton will attract hp's
electron and hp's proton will attract a
chaise electron okay and this will draw
the atoms closer together
okay and so now we've got situation
where they're a little bit closer
together and let's reveal the electrons
there too okay now notice the electrons
are kind of moving down this way right
sort of towards the VV the direction of
that of the proton that's attracting
them okay so I've kind of drawn them in
in a little bit okay they're here now so
this is a little it's moving closer to
this and this one is moving closer to
this you might be thinking wait if this
is happening that means that these
electrons are getting closer together
right and so are these protons that
can't be good right because like charges
repel and that's true okay so there is
an attractive force between the opposite
charges but there's a repulsive force
between the light charges so we just
said that that a chaise proton attracts
HBS electron and hp's proton attracts a
chaise electron that draws the atoms
closer but at the same time a chaise
electron a chaise electron is repelling
HBS electron and that's not the only
repulsive force right these protons are
like charges they're going to be
repelling each other as well so a chaise
proton repels HBS proton okay so there's
the attractive force right there's the
attractive force between the the
opposite charges right so that's this
right here these are the attractive
forces and then there are the repulsive
forces so I got fit this here repulsive
forces okay so what happens is that the
attractive forces of course of drawing
the atoms closer together but these
repulsive forces are doing doing a
certain job at repelling the delight
charges what's going to happen is that
they're not going to stop just there
though they're going to get a little bit
closer okay what's going to happen is
that we'll have this situation now the
electrons are super super
close together right and we just
described these attractive and repulsive
forces and we think and these electrons
here they're really close to each other
they repel that's not good and these
protons are close together and they
would repel each other that's not good
but there's also the attractive forces
okay so I went on I want to show you
guys this so there are attractive forces
between the opposite charges result
reveal here as these little blue lines
so here we got a proton and electron
attracting each other here we've got a
proton electron attracting each other
same thing here and same thing here so
those are all the attractive forces
right between opposite charges but there
are also repulsive forces that we talked
about this here is representing the idea
that these protons are repelling and
also these electrons are repelling okay
but the sum of these forces keeps these
two atoms 8a and HB at a sort of optimal
distance between each other okay there's
a sweet spot where there's like a
balance between these attractive and
repulsive forces so the atoms are close
enough to each other where they like to
be but far enough from each other where
they also like to be there not too close
not too far there's an optimal distance
between the two atoms okay and the
reason why this is good is now both h a
and HB feel like they have a second
electron which makes sense because the
now they feel like their electron
configuration which I'm just going to
abbreviate as config is 1s2 which is the
noble gas configuration of helium right
so one of each of them feel that they
have 1 s 2 and 1 s 2 right even though
there aren't four electrons but they
both feel like they have a second
electron okay so they're sharing
electrons right they're sharing the
electrons and when we have this when we
have a che and HB sort of together like
this with these attractive and repulsive
forces kind of all working together we
have now instead of two separate h atoms
we have h2 diatomic
hydrogen which is called a molecule a
molecule is a unit of matter in which
two or more atoms are held together by
covalent bonds so what we're showing
here and this little drawing is a
covalent bond in fact often it'll be
represented like this we'll have like H
with an electron and age with an
electron over here where that little dot
represents an electron and when they
come closer they end up being like this
we have two H's there's two electrons
between them and oftentimes that's
simply represented by a line to indicate
that that's a bond specifically a
covalent bond between two hydrogen atoms
this concept here is sort of a sneak
peek at that the idea of lewis
structures which i'm not going to talk
about now but i will probably see more
of that later ok ok cool let's move on a
little bit so I just mentioned h2 as an
example of the simplest covalent
compound but covalent compound is just
any any compound that has two nonmetals
combined right so here are some other
examples we have HCl just the hydrogen
atom and a chlorine atom right and
they're going to be sharing electrons
here right that's a covalent bond there
haven't drawn the electrons explicitly
just for the sake of space but they're
going to be electrons they're here h2o
water there's going to be two covalent
bonds right there's gonna be a bond
there between that H and that oxygen and
a covalent bond there between that H and
at oxygen and o2 got two oxygen atoms
one covalent bond between them or
they're going to be sharing electrons
okay now each of these units these units
are called molecules these units are
molecules what's important to realize
super super important to realize is that
each of these molecules is a separate
entity okay you can have one single o2
molecule you can have a single h2o
molecule you can have a single HCl
molecule now this is this is important
to realize because this is different
from an ionic compound because ionic
compounds have formula units and a
formula unit a formula unit simply gives
you the ratio of ions in a crystalline
ionic compound there's no such thing
like
as a as a on ionic molecule nacl for
example is not a molecule nacl just
tells you that if you have a sample of
sodium chloride NaCl that's telling you
that for everyone sodium ion that you
have you have one chloride ion right
it's not necessary that you have just
one sodium ion a one chloride ion
whereas with molecules this is just one
molecule right Oh two that's two oxygen
atoms bound and that is a separate
entity from any other o2 molecule okay I
hope that makes sense a distinction is
important okay now there are situations
in which a small group of atoms can be
covalently bound while being part of an
eye on all together and in that
situation what you have are poly atomic
ions polyatomic ions poly meaning many
atomic referring to adams right and ions
of course referring to ions so you have
many atoms all combined together but
overall they have a charge right so
here's an example co 3 2 minus this is
called carbonate or carbonate ion
carbonate and so we've got one carbon
and we've got three oxygens and overall
that whole situation has to treat me a
charge of negative 2 right and many
polyatomic ion has in fact most of them
that you'll come across are going to be
anions right they'll be negatively
charged there are a few in fact I can
only think of a couple that are
positively charged one of them is NH 4
plus which is called ammonium ion so
monium okay and there's one nitrogen and
four hydrogen's and overall they have a
plus one charge okay so these are
examples of polyatomic ions these are
not covalent compounds but because we
have non metals bound together right
those are covalent bonds okay so we'll
have covalent bonds between these these
non metals but overall the the the
overall charge
be the over there will be an overall
charge so it's not a neutral compound
that's why they're called polyatomic
ions okay hope that video was helpful
thank you for watching if you found that
video helpful don't forget to Like
comment subscribe and share with friends
thank you and happy studying